let's talk about this like about this
one other story just totally off just
random uh from teamcast.com south
carolina schedules first execution since
completion of firing squad chamber whoa
is this a picture of it south carolina
has scheduled its first execution of a
death row inmate since completing the
firing squad chamber is now now hold on
there a minute guys are you saying
they're going to firing squad this
person
they say executions in the state have
been halted for the last decade due to
the difficulty of obtaining the drugs
used for lethal injections leaving 35
death row inmates in limbo last year
they made the electric chair their
primary method for carrying out death
but said that they would give inmates an
option to choose death by firing squad
or lethal injection
panel
which would you prefer lethal injection
electric chair firing squad
i'm definitely gonna go with the firing
squad for the coolness factor though i'm
pretty sure the lethal injection is
probably uh nothing more painful though
it's the most painful it could be like i
guess it depends on how because the
cocktail has been messed up before right
no no no it literally is it is okay yeah
they paralyze you first so you can't
express the pain
but uh it's my understanding cause i
read a lot about it is that lethal
injection is actually a slow
excruciating death
no i would think that electric chair
would be the worst right yeah but yeah
but yeah no i would go with fire your
eyes like don't they like boil and burst
off oh my gosh
yeah i think carbon monoxide poisoning i
don't know why they don't do that they'd
that would be painless
yeah they actually do they have these
suicide pods where they gradually
increase the level of carbon oh yeah
where was that like in sweden or
something yeah we talked about that
before the suicide cruise i picked
firing somebody watched too much feature
on yeah exactly gross but i'd have to
take the firing squad i think i'd take
the firing squad firing squad yeah
honestly i think firing squad would
probably be the least painful did they
get rid of it because they didn't want
the soldiers to feel guilty about like
who hit the killing bullet no no that's
why they do it yeah exactly no one knows
who actually killed the person right i
think one of them has a gun with blanks
in it or something like that really yeah
interesting wow and so you could be the
one with the and then the blanks yeah
everyone you don't know that's perfect
but it's also it's it's i mean i guess
the problem with the firing squad is
like what if they all hit your stomach
that
i don't know to be honest what do you
guys think of well first of all so i
oppose the death penalty i don't i would
prefer none of these things and um the
issue i have with it is if you've
contained someone already i don't see a
reason to end their life like they're
they're not don't let them out obviously
if they're like serious offenders but if
they're like locked in a concrete box
what sucks is like
you got to pay for them you've got to
pay for their food and their life and
everything and that's more than a lot of
people deserve that's for sure but then
it's just a scary thought to me to be
like
killing people you know what i mean
yeah but how is locking them away
forever working right we don't do that
like that's the problem is that we we do
all this early release stuff you know
something comes out you have covet
issues or you know someone can be re
rehabilitated that would be a better
option that actually used to be right
that was the worst penalty you could
receive in a lot of cultures was you
know you just were you know sent to the
hinterlands and you couldn't but but now
you know global community it's not as
big a punishment as it used to be i mean
if let's let's play this game um
electric chair lethal injection firing
squad or they put you in a little dinghy
and kick you off into the ocean i take
the ocean on that one you see most
people would be like yeah but that's
just you starve to death
they kick you out into into
international waters and say good luck
at least got a chance yeah that what do
you think other countries would say
they'd be like dude your murderers are
washing up on our shores
they're not sending their best okay
they're not sending their best to us
i mean i guess there's like islands you
know you can just eat coconuts or
whatever so what do you guys think about
death are you for the death penalty what
do you guys think nah i don't think he's
bad you're pretty against it by nature
what sheamus what are you feeling i'm
not yeah i i don't uh i lean yeah
against i would say i lean towards
against but it's it's not something i've
like completely worked out
do you think yeah i'm pro like you you
have a situation where uh people do
heinous things you need a good deterrent
you need to send a message for those
things and like i said also the and you
know the indefinite uh incarceration
thing i think is in often crueler but on
top of that is also extremely costly and
unlikely to occur in the long run as
societies find ways to release these
here's my question for you how many
innocent people are you willing to kill
to guarantee you kill the bad guys well
again the oh this is always the question
of all rule enforcement throughout all
society right how many innocent people
are we willing to lock away in prison
how many people are we willing to kill
and the answer is you're always going to
have fault any any legal system is going
to have some level of failure i i got it
i get it but how many innocent people
would you personally be willing to kill
to make sure the bad guys get killed
again i don't have a hard number but it
would be greater than one yeah uh you
see that i have a problem with that
right if there's but one righteous
person i i i don't trust the state i
don't trust people like kamala we've
seen how she's acted towards people who
were who should have been released from
prison uh people who had evidence
exonerating them and her and her
department was like nah we're gonna keep
them anyway um
the state has more often shown that it's
willing to cover up its faults because
they don't want people to realize they
execute innocent people so they'll lie
about it and execute innocent people and
uh it is better that 100 guilty persons
escaped than one innocent person suffer
my solution to that i suppose is called
the second amendment i look at what the
founding fathers had in mind don't have
innocent people suffer everybody gets
guns and i'm like okay well that means
there may be accidents there may be
conflict but you you leave more up to
the individuals to defend themselves
it's their personal responsibility and
you leave more up to uh the state i mean
the state backs away from potentially
killing innocent people which it has
even even in the founding fathers time
the the issue i i find here with the
death penalty is
if the if the amount of innocent people
is greater than one
then the state is murdering innocent
people and i don't think it's worth it
if you've locked someone in a box
they can't get out
the worst case scenario in this
circumstance is you got an innocent
person locked in a box but at least
you're not killing them and making an
innocent person walk down death row to
an electric chair or a firing squad or a
lethal injection because just imagine
being that person and them saying hey
look we get it you might be innocent but
hey system's got to do what the system
does i say screw that man lock the
person in the box lock them away there's
35 people it sucks but my attitude is i
would personally rather pay
what i could
to keep these people locked up
permanently than to be party to the
execution of an innocent person but it's
not easy though but imagine you're that
family right you're the you're the
family of that victim and now you have
to watch this person
you know
spend a you know five ten years and then
getting out or i don't i don't believe
in retribution so that's you know not i
don't care i i think you should i think
that that's i think that that's part of
justice i think that when you take
someone's life you should pay for it i
think that when you hurt another
person's family that's something you
should pay for i think justice should be
retributive in many ways like eye for an
eye how far do you go eye for an eye i
mean again you know obviously we can we
you can get lost in how harsh you can
get but i think that a system that says
oh this is only for deterrent's sake or
this is only you know that it should
never it should never be uh you know
retributive is is outweighing the rights
of the criminal more than the rights of
the victims and i think that sends a
message and i think over time it always
devolves into a scenario where people
are getting fewer sentences released
early they're being soft on these things
and you inevitably end up in a situation
that we are now where we have we have
crimes that aren't punished in any of
these i don't think those things
correlate like the reason criminals are
being released is because the left is
advocating for their release for stupid
reasons we should have many people
should be in prison much longer and many
people should be in prison much less
non-violent drug offenses it's like come
on
uh but then you get violent defenders
who commit murder and get out in a few
years now that's a problem
i don't i don't think retribution makes
sense an eye for an eye leaves the whole
world blind everyone's got a grievance
against somebody else and they all want
retribution for their perceived slights
and what happens when a report when a
victim
falsely accuses someone or wrongly
because they're emotionally driven and
and and driven by passion instead of
logic so the state
often it's supposed to try its best to
sort the facts and make sure that um
it's proven beyond a reason beyond a
reasonable doubt often they do often
we've seen circumstances where people
like kamala are willing to
leave people to rot in prison even if
they're innocent her her department uh
her office did this um
that's what's been reported that's how
that's how it's been reported and uh and
then i'm supposed to sit back and just
trust the state that they're not making
mistakes and that the retribution is
just
what happens if the state executes an
innocent person because the family
wanted retribution am i let's say a
family member of mine is on death row
and the family's like they did it i know
they did it and so they say we demand
retribution and the state says and we're
going to grant that retribution execute
my friend or family member and then a
day later evidence comes out exonerating
them am i entitled to retribution
against the executioner do i get to put
him on death row because he killed my
loved one the answer should be yes right
where's my retribution against the state
for killing an innocent person that i
loved you don't get it so the problem is
there is no retribution the state kills
people to shut people up they they they
let rioters riot because they don't want
to call because they don't care they put
innocent people in prison in these riots
they arrest innocent people because they
want to avoid riots this is the problem
with the state you just you can't trust
them
you can trust them sometimes for some
things you can cross your fingers but if
the issue is they are not completely
trustworthy then we can't allow the
state to take extreme or permanent
actions because we can't ever confirm
100 what they're doing is right you
shouldn't trust anyone really in that
situation that's up to you to survive on
this reality floor uh i used to be very
pro-death penalty without a question
like yeah if they're if they're a killer
and they're not going to stop kill them
get them out of here but then i started
to think about the nazis and man they
would just
execute people at will and so are the
soviets and like so i didn't i have a
very american blinder on when i think
about things and malice michael malus
has really opened my eyes to this as
well as luke rukowski uh coming from the
soviet union their families are from the
soviet union it's like yo the state is
not like the benevolent god that you
think it is i was really indoctrinated
growing up but wouldn't you say that
different governments do things for
different reasons so like regardless of
how you feel about the death penalty
couldn't you say well you know when
stalin and hitler were killing people
for bad reasons that didn't necessarily
mean there couldn't be good reasons for
another government to do and again this
is someone who i've acknowledged i don't
really have a fleshed out position yeah
you could kill for good i think you
could kill for a good reason to be
honest there there's there's a scaling
question in the death penalty and it it
pertains to war
right uh someone like hitler or stalin
yeah those people die and those people
die because you're in war and they're
actively killing and mass occurring by
the millions and you're trying to
actively stop them my question is if
someone's been actively stopped already
and you know it's like
the i suppose there there's the the
great philosophical question has been
has been asked answered in many ways in
many of these batman comics the the
injustice storyline you guys fans of dc
at all you know when uh joker depending
on which version of the storyline joker
drugs uh superman superman kills lois
superman
loses it and he's like to batman if you
just killed this man these people
wouldn't have died or there's like
another story i can't remember which one
it is but you know joker plants a nuke
and blows up metropolis and superman's
like you could have killed him and saved
millions and then um damien wayne this
isn't the video game i think it's from
the comic as well he's like you've had
every opportunity to stop these
murderers and you don't batman won't do
it and they get out they murder again
and he's like enough and then you know
the justice league goes dark and they're
like just executing criminals and stuff
there's great philosophical questions
about how to handle things my issue
ultimately comes down to i just don't i
don't trust the state i i don't i i've
i've seen a lot of people i don't trust
them these big cities are run by corrupt
lunatics and um i think kamala harris
should terrify people yeah we have laws
in place so you don't have to trust the
state the law you supposed to trust the
law yeah oh he was about to say
something i wanted i was going to say
that your first gulp of inept government
will turn you into a libertarian but i
think at the bottom of that glass
competent government is the key because
it's very tempting to say when you look
at a government that's corrupt and inept
to say just get government out of
everything that's the easy thing right
this is what the right has been doing
and libertarians have been doing for
many years we'll just get my kids out of
the government school then i don't have
to worry what's being taught there we'll
just get my kids away from this
influence you know what happened
happening in the media well i'll just uh
start my own business and then i don't
have to care what's going on with these
things saying that if we just keep
exiting each one of these arenas that
eventually yo you will be able to solve
the problem but the issue is that that
never solves the problem they always end
up coming after you you never just get
to get away right and so the the easy
out is to say we just take the power of
government away right this is this is
what we're we're taught is that we just
reduce the power of government we or we
put checks and balances limit on the
power of government and then therefore
we don't have to worry what government
does because there's the system that
holds it holds it in check for us the
truth is that at the end of the day that
doesn't work that never works the
government always retains that power
someone's always making these decisions
of the state and they are always taking
that power they're always increasing and
centralizing the power the question is
who wields it you want someone competent
you don't just want to pretend like you
can run away forever thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there